à bas le temps entrepreneur général
aujourd'hui jeune trio puis je peux même
plus travailler croyez moi la cave 19
ceyzérieu vous avez certainement vu
cette nouvelle publicité du gouvernement
qui veut mettre en lumière les
conséquences possibles dako 20-19 de
publicité qui veut être un traitement
choc pour ceux qui ne croient pas que la
cave et 19 pour vraiment créer des
ravages aux dés les impacts importants
pour la santé
est ce que ça fonctionne comme publicité
je pose des questions à arnaud granata
président d'info prince et martin saint
victor stratèges en communication
bonjour à vous deux bonjour curling
alors martine tout d'abord qu'est ce que
vous en pensez de ces publicités losc
est ce que ça marche ça marche parce
qu'on en parle ce matin on en parle
depuis plusieurs jours donc c'est un une
des résultantes d'une publicité qui
marche et ça si on en parle et je crois
que cette publicité là en 30 secondes
brise plusieurs mythes c'est à dire par
exemple que l'aco vide n'a fait que les
vieux c'est faux on le voit le la
personne dans la publicité les jeunes
que c'est comme une grippe non c'est pas
comme une grippe qu'on s'en remettre
facilement et sans conséquence la preuve
c'est que non il a une trachéotomie il a
été dans le coma
donc je pense qu'à ce niveau là la
musique fonctionne absolument puisque on
essaie d'attaquer ses mythes qui perdure
depuis depuis six mois et vous savez les
publics les publicités chocs ont en
effet il ya une tradition au québec de
s'enlacer la société
d'assurance-automobile le fait depuis
des décennies avec des publicités très
chaud comme on voit des accidents de
voiture ces graphiques mais on s'en
souvient on en parle c'est une tradition
qu'on peut retracer aux états unis avec
sûrement que vous en souvenez dans les
années 80 il y avait cette grande
campagne pour contre la drogue et on
avoue on avait mis en scène un oeuf en
train d'offrir et en faisait le
comparable de notre cerveau sur la
drogue
et ça c'est une publicité aujourd'hui
qui a encore des effets donc la publier
de l'aco vide suis un peu cette
tradition-là de choquer les gens de
rendre les gens malades
et aussi en même temps de faire passer
un message très très loin de votre côté
vous voyez ça comment est ce que sap
touche la cible que le gouvernement
voulait atteindre mais je pense que je
suis d'accord avec martine sur le fait
que médiatiquement c'est un succès parce
qu'on en parlait d'ailleurs on en parle
ce matin par contre moi la question que
je me suis posée en voyant cette
publicité c'est à qui ça s'arrête parce
que si ça s'adresse aux personnes qui
d'autre que là que vittek existence j'ai
pas l'impression que cette publicité va
va les faire changer d'avis c'est un peu
comme de penser qu'on va faire changer
d'avis un climato sceptiques par contre
si on s'adresse aux jeunes je sais pas
non plus si c'est une publicité qui va
leur parler parce que ils vont peut-être
s'en détacher il me semble que les
dernières publicités du gouvernement
avec la horde avec sarah mais on était
basée plus sur de l'inspiration
si elle veut envoyer un message par
contre que l'aco vide c'est sérieux et
envoyer un message à ceux qui se
protègent déjà
alors oui ça va nourrir la peur et ça va
je pense que ça annonce aussi ce qui
s'en vient c'est à dire des vagues d'une
deuxième vague et des zones peut être
encore plus rouge dans certains endroits
du québec
donc pour renforcer finalement les
gestes de provocation que les gens
mettent en place côté qu'il y en avait
qui avait levé la garde un petit peu
donc ça rappelle aux gens l'importance
mais pour aller toucher le public qui
madère por aux mesures qui n'adhèrent
pas finalement à ce que québec demande
pour essayer d'aplatir la courbe
c'est un peu raté martin je ne dirais
pas que c'est raté particulièrement
parce que c'est pas vous savez il n'ya
pas une formule magique qui a pas un
élément qui va arriver tous nos
problèmes c'est un peu comme un quartet
ou quintet et plusieurs éléments
cette publicité là est diffusé à la
télévision elle est diffusée sur le web
donc je crois qu'elle va chercher une
partie de la population
arnaud mentionnait la série publicité
avec leur décès a ramené ça va chercher
une autre partie de la population et
c'est ce que ça prend c'est pas c'est
impossible d'avoir un message qui va
tenir de longs mois qui va toucher toute
la population
donc c'est un effort qui doit être
vraiment segmenté sur veut jamais
recette vous parler maintenant de ce que
le parti de françois legault voulait
lancer donc nouvelle web série qui
s'appelait confidences d'un premier
ministre avec un soin legault ça devait
commencer cette semaine le 1er octobre
finalement ça a été retiré mais on va
regarder la façon dont s'est élancé
[Musique]
donc on finance d'un premier ministre
avec françois legault
le politicien le plus aimé des québécois
qu'est ce qu'il faut en penser de cette
web série finalement qui a été retirée
me dit on du côté de la cac en raison de
la pandémie puis la hausse de la courbe
arnaud vous voyez ça comment écoutez
j'ai été assez étonné de voir ça
arrivait sur serein sur internet hier je
suis pas étonné par contre 6 a été
retiré je sais pas si c'est pas à cause
de la deuxième vague plus que des
commentaires nombreux et peut-être pas
très élogieux que cette que cette vidéo
que cette annonce de cette émission a
reçu mais non c'est un très très mauvais
timing en effet on a plus l'impression
que c'est entre un mélange de film
d'action et de et en même temps il ya
aussi cette grande tradition regarde un
peu partout dans le monde
monsieur mélenchon en europe avait lancé
sa propre chaîne télé aux états unis ça
c'est ça c'est vu plus souvent
qu'autrement
donc il ya cette volonté de contrôler le
message mais en même temps c'est
tellement pas le moment en ce moment on
est dans une situation sanitaire
tellement dramatique
je pense que c'est un mauvais timing qui
ont fait pas ça non plus au québec est
traditionnellement mal vous l'avez vu
comment cette web série qui est
peut-être important plus tard on verra
moi aussi j'étais très étonnée qu'elle
souhaite qu'elle soit annoncée comme ça
avec tambours et fanfare comme arnaud je
crois pas que ce soit le timing je pense
qu'on l'aura on a rappelé à la cahc que
le timing était mauvais je crois qu'il
n'avait pas réalisé ce que je trouve
particulier avec ça c'est que pour
l'instant les messages du gouvernement
sont non partisan on concentre le
message sur la pandémie qui va être on
ne sait pas si elle sera plus sérieuse
si la deuxième axe sera plus plus mortel
que la première on ne sait pas donc tous
les messages devraient concentrer sur ça
or cette web série c'est un message
partisans et fêter et c'est une version
moderne de de ce qu'on a déjà vues a
mentionné monsieur mêlant chant et aussi
aux états unis aux etats unis une
tradition qui existe depuis les années
30 avec los verdes qui le faisait avec
avec le moyen de communication de
l'époque c'est-à-dire la radio et c'est
une tradition qui a perdu
jusqu'à barack obama c'est une manière
pour les politiciens de faire passer ce
qu'ils ont à dire d'une manière
contrôlée sans se faire interrompre dans
les questions des journalistes m voilà
c'est pour éviter les médias c'est
absolument ça et je pense qu au delà du
times et que je suis même pas sûr qu'on
soit prêt ici au québec à avoir ce genre
de communication là de la part de nos
politiciens et j'ai l'impression que ça
alimente aussi le cynisme d'une certaine
façon c'est vrai qu'elle est beaucoup
beaucoup de réaction là la suite de la
publication de la vidéo finalement ça a
été retirée on verra si c'est reviendra
dans le temps dans quelques instants on
regarde l'ensemble les images la semaine
les événements qui ont marqué les
derniers jours vous avez fait votre
choix vous avez décidé quelle image a eu
le plus d'impact au cours des derniers
jours
et pourquoi alors via de vous entendre
dans les prochaines minutes
[Musique]